and so but the thing is failure we all
we just learned failure is great
the best thing to do is to fail and i
told you what i told my daughter please
keep failing a few
you and times
prophet are following off doubling the
money in three years it's a great idea
but instead of investment is there some
other ways to compound at fast pace
he's asking besides
besides the investing way
what other ways can we make money fast
you know we have talked about that you
can invest and make money what other
ways can you make money being
entrepreneur you can make one to million
in 10 years
i mean you can be another facebook you
can be another i mean entrepreneurship
is the fastest i mean there is only one
guy who has made half trillion by buying
other companies stocks
only buffett has made money now out of
500 riches guys only buffett is the only
person who has made money a lot of money
by buying other persons uh businesses
otherwise all the 499 guys they're
richest i mean like bill gates or mark
zuckerberg or
boozers they're all entrepreneurs
entrepreneurship is the fastest way of
making money so in my case
my portfolio is only 2500 crores
that's interesting
but my company is 20 000 crores
in the same period
because
most of the money was on the other side
yeah now we are getting the real numbers
now we have to compound the this portion
of the 20 000
what
and it can be
truly exponential in digital age
everything is exponential so you know so
basically
actually the investing way
is a slow way
to to make money you're right
the faster way is
uh to start your own business
right but the faster way
is also got
high failure rate
right
and so but the thing is failure we all
we just learned failure is great
the best thing to do is to fail and i
told you what i told my daughter please
keep failing a few times
and
and so
so the you know the other thing that you
can keep in mind is
that
when you're working for someone you're
only allowed are supposed to work 40-50
hours a week
okay normally that's what they expect
there are 168 hours in a week
and a lot of businesses you can start
with no money you know especially
technology business you can be in your
home with a computer you can start a
business so it is very easy to have at
least another 40-50 hours
while someone is paying you
to have second business like i told my
daughter about half time
even if she works full-time she still
has time uh to spend 450 years so what
you can do is keep a job
and then keep doing startups first one
fail forget next one fail forget keep
going fifth sixth seventh it will work
and you only need one to work
and that's it
and uh how many successful businesses
are you started around there
i started only only one only one only
one so
you didn't need to do many of them and
uh so that's the beauty of it but it
didn't work for the first five years
right first five years very tough that's
right from 86 to 90 it was very tough i
mean we didn't know uh whether uh we are
going to be successful because making a
lack of something with two characters
with full family and all it was not that
big a deal that's right only after five
years we realized that we are successful
and we made from 15 lakhs to 30 crores
in next 18 months that's the power of
entrepreneurship when you hit big when
you hit success it's completely
exponential and uh one one thing while
he was saying it hit me
that if you have a iit degree which you
will have
your downside is no see nobody on this
earth can take out your id degree
that's your lowest denomination
so like
i keep telling the guys nobody can't see
i don't speculate in the market i only
invest so invest can my 2500 quotes can
become 100 crores or 200 or maybe it can
become zero advice at worst
but nobody can take away my uh ca degree
i can always go to monash and say one is
give me fifty thousand dollar job he
will be very happy to give me that job
you know so you always have downs always
look at your downside what is the worst
and worst can be your id degree which
will give you 15 20 lakhs so why worry
play the whole life
all the way
take all the risk risk miss calculator
is not a speculation
i am saying start entrepreneurship fail
once failed twice wealth thrice success
is
[Music]
you